hello so welcome to the webinar this is
Perry Clavin and this is Jeremy Utley
glad to be with you today so we're going
to dive right in the topic for today is
how to make innovation a reality in your
work and the framing that we're going to
use for the talk today is actually
refuting four myths about innovating the
workplace we find that it's important
before beginning to engage in the
practices of design to innovate in your
workplace to have a right concept of
what innovation means and what it
requires so we're going to start by
telling a few stories and talking about
some common myths that people hold about
innovation in the workplace so the myths
are the lone rogue it's an easy sell the
customer knows best and it's a lightning
bolt so these might seem a little
cryptic but we're going to go through
them one at a time and tell you a case
or a story about each one from our work
alright so the first example we want to
talk about the first myth that we want
to debunk is the myth of the lone rogue
or the innovator in isolation we see
that many organizations believe that
individuals are responsible for
innovation and that individuals alone
have the inspiration required to
innovate and that's something that that
we want to debunk we're going to do that
by telling a quick story of a good
friend of ours named Doug Dietz Doug is
an executive on the global design team
at GE healthcare and encountered us at
the d.school
about five years ago doug is responsible
for designing many of the imaging
machines at GE healthcare such as the
one that you see on your screen below
Doug came to an executive program at
Stanford where we taught many of the
principles of design thinking that we
teach to executive education students
and we asked a simple question at the
end of his
what do you plan to do when you go back
home what simple activity can you engage
in to begin to innovate in your work and
for Doug who designs medical equipment
his answer was he wanted to go visit
hospitals and actually see people
engaging with his machines so that did
and the hospital that he actually
visited was a Children's Hospital just
happened to be a Children's Hospital
Doug had recently won an award for
designing a imaging machine that won an
international industrial design award so
he's very proud of the machine he went
and spoke with several doctors and
nurses and they all told him what he
already knew which was it was a great
machine it made great scans and I was
the top of its class technologically but
while he was there and while he was
speaking with some of the technicians
one of the nurses came in and said Doug
I've got asked to leave for a moment we
have a patient coming up and so Doug
said he stepped out in the hallway and
as he did he saw a young couple walking
down the hallway and there they were
both holding hands of a little girl
about six years old he said that as they
were walking down the hallway he noticed
that the little girl was crying and she
was saying I don't want to do it I don't
want to go I'm scared and her parents
were saying as you might imagine you can
do it you you can be brave you're going
to be strong he said he knows that she
didn't have any hair so it's clear that
she was undergoing some type of serious
treatment but he said he couldn't figure
out what she was scared of and and so
anyway he stepped out of the exam room
and when they came in when they rounded
the corner and the little girl saw the
machine that he was so proud of the
machine that he had won so many awards
for he said that she burst into tears
and was overwhelmed with fear and he
watched all this unfold he watched her
unable to keep still which is very
important for the equipment that he's
designed so the point that the the
doctors had to bring in an
anesthesiologist to come in to sedate
this little girl as you can imagine it
was a very traumatic experience
certainly for Doug but even more for the
family that he was watching and
certainly unhealthy for the little girl
he said that in that moment he went from
thinking that he was huge success to
realizing that at least in this regard
he had failed so a user that he was
designing for he said that he wasn't
sure whether this case was an anomaly or
was straightforward and was the typical
case so he said he started asking
doctors and nurses that he knew hey how
often does do do children have to be
sedated how often are they scared and he
said they learned roughly four out of
five kids roughly 80% of kids have to be
sedated when they undergo a procedure in
one of the machines that he designed and
he was floored by that statistic as I
think any of us would be he was
absolutely shocked that so many of the
of the patients that had to undergo
procedure one of the unit's machines
were so scared that they couldn't keep
still and had to be sedated he saw this
as a major opportunity not only to
improve kids lives but also to improve
the bottom line of the hospitals because
as a major throughput issue for
hospitals that have to increase their
staffing and increase the time for a
procedure so he began to work on the
problem and we're going to cut right to
the chase to show what he designed but
over the course of engaging with these
kinds of users he realized that what
kids really needed in their lives was
adventure and where as their brothers
and sisters would go to sports camp and
would play various sports and and spend
time outdoors because of these kids
medical situation and illness they were
unable to engage in the same kinds of
activities and so Doug and his team
ended up designing what you see on your
screen now which is a series of devices
geared towards infusing adventure into
the medical procedures they had to
undertake there are over 20 such
machines in hospitals around around the
u.s. now it's still a pilot but what
Doug and his team have uncovered is if
they can bring adventure into the lives
of children they can dramatically
improve the experience for the child and
also dramatically improve the experience
for the hospital in the 20 plus
hospitals
where they've deployed this machine
called the adventure series they've
brought sedation rates down
exponentially one thing that's
interesting to note is this team has not
innovated based on a better technology
the the product is actually
technologically exactly the same but
what they've done is they've completely
changed the experience of kids and in so
doing they generated millions of dollars
of sales for GE and brought patient
satisfaction levels up to over ninety
percent from previous loads of in the
single digits in addition many families
have reduced their trauma obviously and
many kids have had a completely new
experience of what it means to undergo a
medical procedure like this the thing
that we want to point out those that
Doug was not alone Doug did not do this
on his own
in isolation inspired as a single and
innovator but rather he took our advice
and he assembled a team of diverse
experts folks ranging from kindergarten
teachers and curators of children's
museums and Child Life specialists you
see Doug's team had previously only
collaborated with itself a bunch of
designers with expertise in industrial
design and in mechanics and they never
thought about bringing in outsiders to
actually bring a fresh perspective on
into their team and into their work and
when Doug encountered a new challenge of
trying to design for the delight of
children who were in terminal illness
situations he recognized that his team
was woefully inadequate in terms of the
expertise that was resident on the team
and so at our encouragement and
instruction he brought on a radically
diverse set of collaborators to help him
bring fresh eyes to the problem he jokes
that the GE personnel HR office called
asking hey why are we why why do we have
kindergarten teachers on the payroll why
are we employing folks from Children's
Museum's
because they were unfamiliar
with bringing in such a radically
diverse team know what Doug experienced
in bringing such a radically diverse
team together is that the diversity of
perspectives allowed him and his team to
see the problem in a fundamentally
different way than they've been able to
see it before and well let's see we see
time and time again at Stanford is that
when organizations are approached with a
very difficult challenge which forces
them to draw upon expertise that's
beyond the expertise of their team that
forces them to collaborate outside of
their meet disciplinary boundaries
oftentimes what's needed is a radically
diverse team with a radically diverse
skill set and so loan innovators are not
themselves able to sustain and deliver
breakthrough innovations but rather they
need to be complemented with diverse
perspectives and still sets in order to
deliver breakthrough innovations so the
one more example this was a we thought
an important topic and I think one of
the things that sort of perpetuates that
innovation is a story of a lone inventor
so this idea of diverse teams and sort
of reveling in the diversity of the team
in different perspectives and I'll talk
about how you make a team like that work
in one of the other myths but for now
just one more quick example Patagonia is
a clothing company for those you don't
know it makes outdoor clothing down
jackets fleece and wool and some
terrific company based in Southern
California founded by the Shannara
family Ivana Melinda Jannard
amazing history founded in the 70s gives
back 1% of its profits for environmental
causes and builds all its products as
sustainably as possible anyway what the
years I was there in the early 2000s
working with a great team we were
challenged with starting a surf product
line and the approach we took was was to
use design process but but further to
put together a diverse team and this
diverse team was
he gave an interesting product
breakthrough and I want to tell the
story just briefly by putting surfers
together for those of you that are
surfers you might recognize the picture
here's its upper right hand corner Gerry
Lopez is the famous surfer from the 70s
but we also had surfers on the team that
were you know pros at the time and we
had of course designers that we're going
to design a clothing you know but the
interesting thing is we put which is not
commonly done in a sounds it sounds very
obvious well we put fabric designers the
people actually develop the fabrics on
the team and folks from operations and
folks from sales and all these
perspectives mix together throve a very
unique breakthrough Patagonia produced a
wetsuit which in my mind is still one of
those innovative wetsuits on the market
made with wool so traditionally wetsuits
are made of neoprene and this is a
product made of wool and it allows the
wetsuit to be dramatically lighter
antibacterial and all these terrific
things about it and it came from this
directly from this diverse team
I remember the fabric designer on the
team early on because he was in that
early early session dreaming about what
products would be for the surf line and
dreaming about the changes that could be
made he also was an expert in fabrics
and very very early on had the idea that
you know maybe we didn't have to use the
fabrics that were used by everybody else
to make wetsuits maybe we could try some
other ones so very early on in the
development of the product line this
diverse perspective was brought into the
team and completely broke the mold for
what a wetsuit could become so as a
result these are the the lightest and
thinnest wetsuits you can get and really
gave Patagonia a chance to enter the
market with something dramatically
different and a direct result of a very
diverse team working on it not the
results of a lone inventor the fabric
designer on his own would not have been
successful without the team around them
so with that moving on to the next met
one of the myths
we want to debunk is the fact that
innovations neatly sell I think that far
too often when inventors tell their
story it comes off as it was easy they
made this breakthrough in the world be
to past my door I'll tell you a personal
story here that I sure you that's not
the case when I was a graduate student
here at Stanford a student of David
Kelly's and product design at the end of
your your degree you had to come up with
an invention so I chose of all things to
invent a new snowshoe
so traditionally here in the picture at
that point in the early 90s snowshoes
were for pretty much all wood and
rawhide or nylon and very very heavy
very hard to use snowshoe was not a
sport per se wasn't something you really
did but I I actually got interested in
it because I'd broken my leg in graduate
school and couldn't ski and decided to
snowshoe and it didn't have a great
experience they decided to design a new
pair snowshoes and you can see on the
right what came of it was a you know
aluminum and and a neoprene and very
very sort of high-tech snowshoe with it
with a binding and pleats and all these
systems in it
it was very innovative loads of patents
all this great stuff and it allowed
people to to run in snowshoes a lot of
people to backcountry snowboard name the
company that was snow shoe company
thought the logo the name was really
cool you know decided to build all the
snowshoes and certainly went out to the
trailheads and got loads of people
jazzed every weekend with these products
but I assure you at this point the world
did not be to pass my door I did not
make the cover of Fortune magazine it
took many many years but one of the
critical things with was snow showing
becoming a larger activity was getting
ski resorts to allow it and getting the
mountain areas that people wanted and
had access to in the winter to actually
embrace snowshoeing and you know you
tell the story it's amazing to me in
hindsight to say it took every bit of
five years to convince the four
first of the big ski resorts to actually
allows ocean in the round it was it was
something they turned away they thought
it was silly they thought it was going
to cause injuries they thought it was
going to slow down the revenues in other
areas and Vail associates was the first
one to allow snowshoeing this is the the
first map I kept we eventually had lots
of ski areas added over the years but
it's something I like to sort of use as
an example of the persistence it takes
this these innovators to see their their
innovations to market and make it happen
and it's not an easy sell it was a long
effort to get snow shoeing accepted and
it wasn't a result of that first
inspiration of a would snowshoe not
having to be so heavy and so bulky in
making a lighter one it was a result of
an effort to persist an effort to bring
it to market and tell the story over and
over and over and finally convinced in
this case a really big operator to allow
snowshoeing and that's something that we
actually hear time and time again as we
talk with innovators it's very easy when
those of us who are observing
breakthrough innovations healing a
market and then hearing the stories the
story is told retrospectively often make
things sound very simple and very easy
and we're able to retrospectively piece
together a beautiful story arc that
makes sense to those who are listening
but the reality is when you're looking
forward in the face of uncertainty in
the face of the unknown trying to bring
something to bear in the market which
has never been done before all of the
courses in the market are against you
and in many times even forces within
your own organization are against you we
joke that the antibodies of the
organization come out to attack anything
that seems unfamiliar and anything that
seems as if it might threaten the
existence and success of existing lines
of business even in the example like
that we mentioned earlier of Doug at GE
he even had trouble convincing his
organization that this that the problem
of children and being sedated in imaging
machines was a problem worth working on
he actually started by collaborating
with a partner hospital because the
hospital experienced that problem even
more acute
than his own organization did and so
time and time again we see that true
innovators people who are truly
interested in disrupting the market has
to be willing to have a thick skin has
to be willing to take a few arrows a few
punches get a few black eyes and bloody
noses but has to truly believe in what
they're trying to achieve and we talked
about empathy and a deep concern for the
customer as a way to build that passion
build that inspiration and fuel the
momentum that's required to actually
beat the odds inside of your
organization and out so if that will
move to the third myth because there's a
lot of talk about I'm listening to your
customer and the customer knows best and
while we wholeheartedly agree that it's
important to empathize with your end
customer and develop a deep
understanding of their needs we actually
believe that it's a myth that the
customer knows best it's a little
counterintuitive so we'll give a quick
example that hopefully illustrates the
point in the mid-80s Procter & Gamble
owns Folgers toffee they still owned
Folgers coffee but in the mid 80s
Folgers coffee was in a bit of an
identity crisis what they did a bunch of
market research and basically as we hear
the story what came out of the market
research is that they learned the coffee
category has been declining for 20 years
they heard that young people they talked
to young people they did focus groups
and they're the direct quote in the
marketing report was young people will
never drink coffee
Folgers talk to all their customers and
the only thing they found out was their
customers are dying off and they
believed and told the executives of
Procter & Gamble that there's no way to
make money in this category that was a
direct quote to the board no way to make
money in this category they obviously
did not see the tide shifting right and
shortly thereafter Howard Schultz and
Starbucks reinvigorated the marketplace
and reintroduced a new generation to
coffee and the joys and the pleasures of
coffee we think this is an interesting
example because it
clear that listening to your customer
and believing exactly what your customer
says is not always the best way to
proceed and because they approach the
problem that way Folgers and many and
many organizations like holders mistook
what their customers were saying for for
the truth and they believed that their
product was about a specific product and
rather than being about an experience
and they defined coffee as a product
that sat in someone's pantry rather than
as an experience that could be wholly
redesigned wholly reimagined and could
become a completely new and fulfilling
part of someone's life and we see that
time and time again that there's this
subtle difference between seeking out
understanding of your customer and
seeking direction from your customer we
believe it's imperative that you seek
understanding from your customer but to
take direction from your customers can
often lead you astray so I'm going to
talk about that word especially sympathy
for a moment the word empathy the
Webster's definition is here the
intellectual identification with or
vicarious experiencing of the feelings
thoughts or attitudes of another this is
something that we talk about much more
extensively in our course and the
innovation and entrepreneurship
certificate but we wanted to say a few
words about empathy here just to
differentiate what it means between
taking directions from your customer
versus understanding your customer we
think it's very important to get beyond
what your customer saying to understand
what they're feeling
oftentimes market research goes as far
as to explain what someone says and it
compiles a lot of what people say but
rarely does it get into the emotions
behind what they're saying and what we
believe is imperative that a great
designer and great innovator actually
infer meaning from what's being stated
by a customer we seek to understand and
to gain insights from emphasizing with
customers not to gain directives not to
gain direction but to gain insight that
actionable for the team it's still the
job of the design team to innovate it's
not the job of the customer to innovate
Henry Ford famously said if I had asked
my customers what they wanted they would
have set a faster horse we've all heard
that quote and yet again and again and
again we make the mistake of asking our
customers what they want just because we
shouldn't ask our customers what they
want doesn't mean we shouldn't ask them
what they feel though and what we
encourage folks to do is to gain a deep
understanding of your customers and your
users needs so that you might actually
gain a level of insight that allows you
and inspires you to do something they
could never have imagined to do we think
about this insight as being a
combination of observation and inference
observations are very important right we
actually do need to go into the market
place observe our customers ask them
good questions ask them what but just as
important is the other part of this
which is making inferences based on our
own objective experience expertise and
uses ourselves so that we might ask the
question why and dig deep into making
inferences and understanding why this is
something that our late colleague and
predecessor Bill Moggridge pioneered an
understanding that insights must go
beyond observations it isn't enough for
Folgers just to ask young people if
they'll drink coffee it's not just
enough to ask how much longer do we
think our existing customers are going
to live what we have to do is go way
deep more deeply into understanding the
social behaviors and patterns of a new
generation to understand the need for
connection the need for identities and
needs for a place to connect that's
outside of work at home and leveraging
those insights we can redefine and
reframe the opportunity space for our
organizations and for our products in a
way that we can't if we just ask for
directions from our customers one way
that we do this is a simple tool again
we go through this tool and much more
depth in our course but wanted to at
least expose folks to this but it's a
simple tool
as a way to think about unpacking
observations from our users this this
will we called a user empathy map but
it's a four quadrant diagram on the left
there's specific observable behaviors
and statements that our users make and
if you think about going out into the
into your place of work your place of
business out into the wild so to speak
out into the field to observe your
customers and your users in the day to
day lives
you can think about bucketing what
people say and what people do and
actually cataloging and making notes
about what people say what people do but
then just as importantly and something
that we often overlook is making
inferences and jumping to the right side
of this diagram making inferences about
what people think and what people feel
oftentimes these are implicit rarely are
they explicitly stated usually they're
guesses but they're educated guesses and
we don't make these guesses for the
purpose of flippantly guessing or
postulating but we believe in rapid
cycles and rapidly iterating and as
quickly as we can make guesses getting
back in front of our users and customers
to confirm my hypotheses and it's only
in this manner of making observations
and then shoring up those observations
with inferences that we can test
hypotheses that we can test through
prototypes and through unexpected
interactions with our users that we can
actually break through the unexpected
territory so I want to tell you one more
example with his myth and what I want to
redeem the Procter and Gamble's books we
shared the folders example Procter &
Gamble is a great example of a company
that's adopted many of the methods we
teach here at Stanford of the b-school a
diverse team claudia Koshka is somebody
you should you look up who is the VP in
charge of the efforts at Procter &
Gamble in the 2000s to bring in clear
processes around innovation along with
AG Lafley Cindy Tripp and literally
hundreds of people that did that group
trained up to have
some of the techniques to drive
innovation and in particular wanted to
talk about this this product that mr.
cleaned it's a mr. clean is a division
of Procter & Gamble which is in the tens
of billions of dollars huge huge company
and they were in identity crisis they
were a liquid cleaners division and they
had plateaued they were flat as a
business unit and Claudia and her team
came in and helped them and what they
did was they went on visits to customers
and they told customers we're going to
come in we're from Procter & Gamble we'd
like to know how you use liquid cleaners
we'd like to interview you about your
how you clean your home and what you do
and you know get a little bit of the
empty work that Jeremy's boko trying to
figure out what their needs were and
trying to look deeper for their needs
and as you think about that empty map
that that Jeremy just showed on the
left-hand side they observed something
so over and over they would visit the
homes and they observe something that
the customers never ever said they
observed that the customers had cleaned
up in advance of their visit they had a
clean kitchen counter
they had clean floors and then they went
back and they asked a simple question
they asked why why did you clean up and
customers answered very simply well of
course we cleaned up you know got
visitors got company and they then sort
of dug into the behavior of cleaning
floors and they figured out that well
liquid cleaners and pulling out our old
traditional mop was kind of a drag and
that was there once a week cleaning
ritual but indeed when they were
cleaning up for for guests or a stranger
arriving to do an interview in this case
they would figure out a way with paper
towels or some way to to wipe their
floor off or wipe stains up you know to
do a very very quick cleaning and what
resulted ultimately is a to their own
admission that Procter & Gamble a huge
product you know I think of over a
billion dollar product at Procter &
Gamble the Swiffer which is
basically in between pulling out the mop
and filling a bucket and truly giving
her for flora full cleaning it's
something else you can do with these
liquid cleaners that are terrible's so
great at developing so a great example
of an observed behavior and an inference
and sort of digging deeper with a
customer they didn't come up and say
what I want is you know a handle and a
really really quick cleaning you know
they didn't design that the product the
Swiffer those you've seen it's basically
a a handle that has a head on it that
you can attach if you will almost like
something like a little paper towel but
it already has the cleaning solution in
it and then you can peel it off and
throw it away at the end but the
customer didn't design this for them
they got the insight by visiting the
customers observing behavior and
inferring from them what they wanted
which was the ability to clean up around
the house very very quickly on demand
these little mini cleanups so that we
want to move on to the next myth and
innovation the fact that innovation is a
lightning bolt too often we hear a story
about a breakthrough moment and the
inventor tells the story that this is
the aha moment we would actually tell
you that's not the case that innovation
is a process and this is my favorite
product story of all time but wd-40
those you don't know what wd-40 stands
for it stands for water displacement for
tea and it's because it was the Fortius
try at making this lubricant this is a
lubricant product it's sold throughout
the world it's it's almost ubiquitous
it's a terrific product but the inventor
took 40 tries to get there I think
that's one of the myths of innovation is
often times when you tell a story about
a breakthrough you tell the story only
about that 40th try we would maintain
over and over and over if we dig into it
it's a result of constant iteration and
constant maybe maybe not lightning bolts
but many sparks along the way if you
will little little breakthroughs that
build up to that that big product or
service breakthrough
early in failing often this is a great
graph to look at about how it cost less
to prototype early and cost less to try
things early and fail early I would
maintain this is the graph so for any
breakthrough that any great invention
has gone through multiple iterations
multiple tries at that and it's its
little failures along the way if you
will that each one of these has a little
spark to it maybe leads up to this idea
that there's a big break to at the end
of the big lightning bolt but the result
of all these little mini tries along the
way is what innovation process is about
and the process we teach at Stanford we
call Design Thinking is a series of five
steps empathy defined id8 prototype test
empathize we spend a bit of time on was
one of the myths of getting deep with
our our users finger on what emotions
drive their behavior figuring out what
implicit needs they have and developing
some insights define is a is a way of
synthesizing all of that information
about the customer developing a clear
what we call a point of view or a
problem statement from that it's unique
and usually reframes an area think of a
Swiffer
reframing mopping to to these quick
cleanups id8
is a way of generally commonly one of
the key tools is brainstorming here
generating many many solutions or
innovation potential from that problem
statement prototyping is when you you
get real and you quickly quickly cook
very quickly build these concepts out
low resolution prototyping is a
technique we really like to see see our
students use so how fast can you make
something real is it a key metric and
then finally circling back with our user
so just like the blue hex at the
beginning testings about getting back
with a user learning from those
prototypes almost like probes to learn
more by your customer another way to
think about this is modulating between
two different modalities one is focusing
and the other being flaring too many
times in organizations what we see is
the decision making
and so-called quote it quote unquote
innovation processes are actually just
the product of a long funnel an
ever-decreasing funnel and what we think
is very important is for teams to get
explicit about having shared values
around a process where you oscillate
actually between focusing at times
intentionally focusing but then also
intentionally flaring at other times and
we see the great teams do a good job of
balancing those two modalities but not
only balancing them being explicit about
which modality either end and
recognizing that the modality RN
determines the behaviors and tools you
bring to bear on the process and the
tools you bring to bear in order to
focus in order to make decisions are
very different than the tools you bring
to bear in order to generate options and
to create experiences and it's very
important for creative teams to get
comfortable with and flew it with the
various tools that they have at their
disposal when they're flaring and when
they're focusing every step of the
process that Kerry mentioned earlier has
very specific tools that can be brought
to bear and it's not so important about
a sequence they're in order so much as
having a team shared understanding or
social covenant if you will that there
are times when we're going to bring
certain tools to bear and there are
other times we're going to explicitly
not use those same tools argument is a
great example criticism is a great
example
criticism and argument are very helpful
to make decisions they're very unhelpful
when generating options generating new
ideas and being explicit about are we
criticizing right now or are we not
criticizing right now on a team is
critical because nothing shuts down new
idea generation like criticism that if
the team isn't clear on when they're
engaging in what behaviors then we
engage all behaviors at the same time
and the result is the same kind of
outputs that we always see one example
we wanted to give quickly in closing is
a partner of ours from the class that we
teach at the design school called D
leadership Hyatt Hotels is a large hotel
company over 500 hotels worldwide and
what we saw is as our students engaged
with Hyatt last year this is last
January
we saw that consistency of process was
able to bring a radically diverse team
from frontline workers workers to our
hourly employees all the way up through
management ranks to folks from corporate
headquarters who were coming in to work
on the project consistency of process
allowed everyone on the team to have to
be able to immediately plug in and work
together regardless of hierarchy
regardless of experience or exposure
consistency of process enabled the team
to actually engage in the design process
and avoid the lightning bolt mentality
because everyone with their diverse
functional backgrounds with their
diverse expertise and in the
organization history with hospitality
everyone was brought to a level playing
field in terms of behaviors that were
acceptable for the team workspace by
using a consistent process and we see
this a great example of a radically
diverse team going back almost to the
first bullet point debunking the myth of
the lone rogue it's important if you're
not a lone rogue that you have a
consistent process to engage consistent
language that you use with a radically
diverse team so that you can be on the
same page so that you can speak the same
language but even more than process the
thing that will wrap with and then we'll
open it up for Question and Answer is
having consistent mindsets there are
certain values that we espouse we think
are critical to breakthrough innovation
and we'll close with these but these
values we find across all kinds of
industries all kinds of functions in all
different countries even that that a
focus on human values is critical that a
bias towards action as opposed to
planning or as opposed to talking is
critically important this idea of
showing not telling letting your work
speak for itself embracing
experimentation again as perry mentioned
earlier with the grass experimenting
early seeking out failures early when
they're cheap rather than waiting to
fail and till it's really expensive
radically collaborating as we've
mentioned bringing in diverse teams
diverse backgrounds providing clarity
from complexity not looking for simple
answers from our customers but rather
being willing to handle the messy inputs
they give in crafting clarity as a team
and then lastly as we just mentioned
being mindful of process allowing a
shared knowledge of where we are in a
process to dictate what types of tools
we bring to bear on on our given project
what types of behaviors are acceptable
on our team these shared mindsets on a
team enable a team to go way far beyond
really reach escape velocity and break
out of the confines and box that they
oftentimes find themselves earning
organizations and at this time going to
take the last few moments that open it
up for questions and answers all right
all right so our first question is what
innovations are likely to come from the
target user versus leading-edge users a
great question so this is period I think
that this is something we talk a lot
about it to d.school we call the sort of
that once you get outside of your target
user group we look for extreme users
that's our terminology
it's a terrific point here though that
we absolutely believe you need a healthy
mix of extreme users or edge users as
you do your humpy work let me think a
good example of activity example of
talking to children there are a very
very small percent of the total market
for use of these scanning devices and it
actually shows their needs as
exacerbated so it's much easier to
design a solution for for that type of
user and to the need of needed to be
entertained or in this case the kids
need an adventure and handling their
their fear and anxiety over the
situation is terrific but I know from
talking to Doug that insight applies to
adults as well there is anxiety in
adults and normal you
of those products but that wasn't maybe
the first emotion that came to the
surface if you were to just interview
them but clearly with GE medical that's
an insight now that will be carried
forward in terms of design for the adult
products again and again any one of the
examples were used one of the benefits
of that empathy work is actually to in
terms of using the extreme users is
actually to find those needs and if you
take a look at an edge user whoever sort
of type that question it's a terrific
question those needs are far easier to
expose we find with extreme users so a
great question all right so the next
question that we have is sometimes
innovative people because they think
differently aren't facile with the kind
of business P that gets business leaders
on board it would be interesting
interesting to hear how you would
address that so this is a great question
and I think the reality is as you bring
innovation back into your work and your
job some of it can be new and and scary
to the other folks in your office
folk but we found if you if you even use
the materials in this deck or some of
the trails we're going to share with you
afterwards explaining innovation as a
process and a process they can routinely
drive breakthroughs I think that it to
me debunks a lot of this stuff and
realizing that having empathy for your
co-workers as you go through the process
and explaining a bit of the terminology
some of the diagrams at the end and
we've shown here in terms of explaining
what design process is many many many of
the organizations and small teams we've
worked with simply being clear about
innovation being a process has helped
debunk a lot of the myths and solve a
lot of the problems of miscommunication
with senior folks thing that I would say
just to build on what Barry's saying is
that storytelling is a really powerful
tool it's easy I think often times when
when confronted with a business case
question to feel the need to lead with a
business case
and what we see time and time again both
in grad students as well an organization
as in organizations is that storytelling
is an incredibly powerful and
underutilized tool for building momentum
for building traction inside of an
organization but oftentimes the the
business case can be put can be can be
put on the back burner when a compelling
user centered narrative is told
addressing and uncovering critical needs
that the user or the customer feels even
executives and it may be especially
executives can connect and resonate with
a single user story that's told in a
compelling and meaningful way much
easier than they can with a bunch of
extrapolated facts and figures and so
even using even thinking about how you
design your presentation is really
critical we've seen student teams I
think there's been some research done on
it I'm not exactly sure what the outcome
is but I know for a fact that that's the
d.school student teams are way more
likely to win a business plan
competition or startup competition if
they tell a story before they get
started if they tell a story of their
user leading with the business case
leading with the market opportunity is
rarely what truly grabs people's
attention what captures people's
imaginations or captures people's
imaginations is when they truly believe
there's a problem worth solving and they
truly believe that the team knows how to
solve it and I know that the same is
true in organizations if you can
communicate the urgency of a problem the
urgency of an opportunity then the
solution will sell itself so I'm going
to again thank Jeremy and pray for their
time we've had a lot of questions and so
I appreciate submitting them we're not
going to have time to answer them all we
will try to get to as many as we can so
the next question how much iteration is
needed I think that Jeremy would turn on
air has a great question
iterations as much as as possible I
think it's a one of the things we want
my clear about iteration is it's okay to
launch products that are not fully fully
complete in our minds that iteration is
constant even with products live in the
marketplace we've seen the more nimble
organizations able to even even in their
prototyping process as they're iterating
push products to market at least with
smaller launches testings live high
hotels in particular you know I know if
you go to the the Santa Clara Hyatt
today in California they're trying many
experiments in their Lobby about meeting
places and changing the nature of how
people use their Lobby
they'll be constantly iterating those
they have some really rough prototypes
behind the scenes they're not ready to
be put in front of guests but they they
push things live bitter not at all
bye-bye sort of if you will by the Hyatt
rulebook complete and ready for prime
time with their customers but they'll
indeed push them live and I'd say that
iterations a a mindset it's a mindset
Jeremy showed on that that last slide of
embracing experimentation as an
organization in a a cultural bias to try
as much as talk or hopefully in spite of
talking to actually try it with a
customer and it doesn't mean that we
wouldn't see the mistakes or failures as
things are going to stop the project but
things you're constantly learning and
really buying into this this speed of
iteration that as you learn you're going
to quickly iterate quickly change and
push forward one thing we I think that I
would say just to build on that is that
it's it's critical to start early it's I
think it's less important thing about
how many iterations are necessary it's
less important answer that question that
it is to answer the question when should
you start and the sooner you start the
less you risk an idea becoming too
precious to fail for you and oftentimes
what you see is the longer you marinate
on an idea the longer you think about an
idea the more likely you are to want to
insulate it from failure insulate it
from any kind of criticism and so as
soon as you've got an idea that's the
right time to begin to prototype and as
soon as you prototype that's the right
idea at the right time to begin
iterating
well I want to thank him this brings us
to the close of our webinar I want to
thank again Jeremy and Perry for their
time and for all of you for attending